nos dicen esta tabla nos muestran
algunos valores de la función f y nos
dan esta tabla y nos dicen cuánto es f x
cuando x vale 2 345 cuál condición te
permitiría concluir que existe un valor
máximo para f en el intervalo cerrado 24
elige una respuesta bien pausa el vídeo
y pepsi puedes encontrar la respuesta
ok aquí hay una clave si el problema
habla de la existencia se dice que
existe entonces estamos casi seguros que
necesitaremos trabajar con un teorema de
existencia y si estamos buscando la
existencia de un valor máximo un valor
mínimo entonces lo más seguro es que
estemos hablando del teorema del valor
extremo déjame notarlo
el teorema del valor extremo que a veces
se abrevian como tevé
y para hablar del teorema del valor
extremo tenemos que cumplir la condición
de que nuestra función sea continua en
este intervalo cerrado déjame anotarlo
para que el teorema del valor extremo
pasen necesitamos que la función f
sea continua en el intervalo cerrado 24
entonces vamos a ver cuál de estas
opciones nos ayuda a concluir esta
condición porque si tenemos esta
condición entonces podemos aplicar el
teorema del valor extremo y esto nos
ayudaría ya que el teorema garantiza que
existe un máximo en este intervalo muy
bien vamos a ver la opción am la opción
a me dice que es creciente en el
intervalo abierto 2 3 y decreciente en
el intervalo abierto 35 ok bueno esto no
nos está diciendo que en definitiva
tengamos una función continua en este
intervalo 24 así que voy a cancelarla
porque no podemos garantizar qué
tengamos una función continua en todo
ese intervalo cerrado ok vamos a ver qué
es lo que pasa con el inciso b
efe es continua sobre el intervalo
cerrado 25 ok esto suena mucho mejor
porque si tenemos una función continua
en el intervalo 25 en definitiva vamos a
tener una función continua en el
subconjunto del intervalo 24 que es lo
que buscábamos y ya sabemos si podemos
encontrar esta función continua en este
intervalo entonces podemos aplicar el
teorema del valor extremo ya que
cumplimos las condiciones para poder
aplicarlo y el teorema del valor extremo
nos asegura que existe un valor máximo
en ese intervalo así que me gusta mucho
esta opción creo que esta es la opción
correcta pero no está de más analizar
qué es lo que está pasando con la opción
se vea
la última opción me dice efe
diferenciable en el intervalo abierto 24
y en x igual a 2 bueno esto está muy
cerca porque diferencia habilidad
implica continuidad pero no nos dice qué
está pasando en x igual a 4 la función
podría ser descontinuado justo en ese
valor en x igual a 4 porque observa no
sé qué está pasando en todos los puntos
en este intervalo abierto y qué está
pasando en x igualdad 2 pero falta saber
qué pasa en x igual a 4 así que esta
opción es casi correcta me dice que efes
diferenciable en un intervalo abierto
2,4 y es casi correcta porque diferencia
habilidad implica continuidad pero la
voy a cancelar porque no aseguran que es
lo que está pasando en x igual a 4
en el límite derecho así que ya tenemos
la opción correcta es el inciso b y
vamos a hacer otro de estos ejercicios
así que voy a traer a este ejercicio de
aquí y dice h
es una función diferenciable y me dan
una tabla otra vez con algunos valores
para x y para hd x después dicen a
claudia se le pidió determinar si existe
una solución de la ecuación hdx igual a
menos 2 esto es importante en el
intervalo cerrado menos 13 esta es su
respuesta ok
aquí lo tenemos y me preguntan es
correcto el trabajo de claudia si no es
así cuál es su error escoge una
respuesta pero antes de ver las
respuestas pausa el vídeo e intenta ver
si claudia llego al resultado correcto y
si no lo hizo intenta encontrar en donde
se equivocó
bien lo primero que intentó fue lo
siguiente como queremos un valor en x
donde hdx e igual a menos 2 entonces
ella dijo en el paso 1 - 2 está entre hd
menos 1 y ht3 y eso es cierto lo podemos
ver aquí
htm 1 es este de aquí lo cual es 2 y 7 3
es este equipo lo cual es menos 5 y
observa menos dos están entre 2 y menos
5 aquí podemos meter al valor de menos 2
porque está entre estos dos así que el
primer paso es correcto paso 2 como es
diferenciable sabemos que es continua en
el intervalo cerrado menos 13 bueno esto
también está bien ya lo hemos platicado
diferencia habilidad implica continuidad
ojo continuidad no siempre implica
diferencia habilidad no puedes llegar a
una conclusión así pero
en este caso diferencia habilidad
implica continuidad este es el caso
correcto cuando tenemos una función
diferenciable entonces tenemos una
función continua así que perfecto el
paso 2 también está bien bien paso 1
está bien paso 2 está bien vamos a ver
qué dice el paso 3 el teorema de los
valores extremos garantiza que existe
una solución para htx igual a menos 2 en
el intervalo cerrado menos 1,3 esto
parece un poco tramposo porque el
teorema de los valores extremos dice que
si se cumplen las condiciones lo cual es
cierto tenemos una función continua en
un intervalo cerrado entonces la función
toma un cierto valor máximo y un cierto
valor mínimo sobre ese intervalo
pero aquí no nos interesan los valores
máximos y mínimos lo que nos interesa es
tomar un valor intermedio en este
intervalo un valor entre h de menos 1 y
h de 3
así que claudia está aplicando el
teorema incorrecto debería de aplicar el
teorema del valor intermedio y no el
teorema de los valores extremos así que
voy a tacharlo este es el teorema
incorrecto y si quise hacerlo bien
tendría que poner el teorema del valor
intermedio lo voy a abreviar el teorema
del valor intermedio nos dice que si
tenemos una función continua en un
intervalo cerrado que es lo que tenemos
justo aquí entonces podemos tomar
cualquier valor entre h de menos 1 y ht3
y menos 2 es uno de esos valores entre
hd menos 1 y hd menos 3
así que si aplicamos el teorema del
valor intermedio estaríamos en lo
correcto bien vamos a ver qué dice cada
uno de los incisos para ver cuál es el
que se adecua a lo que acabamos de
concluir así que veamos el trabajo de
claudia en definitiva no es correcto por
lo tanto no es el inciso am
no se equivocó en el paso 1 ya que menos
2 si están entre hd menos 1 y hd 3 lo
vimos acá arriba el paso 2 también es
correcto ya que diferencia habilidad
implica continuidad ok y el paso 3 es el
incorrecto claudia aplicó el teorema
equivocado así que esta es mi respuesta
correcta y hemos acabado todo en este
vídeo nos vemos en el siguiente